hey all you frugal warriors out there
welcome back to another episode of the
iced coffee hour podcast featuring
graham stefan and jack harlow
we are now up to
136.000
dollars and eighty three cents nice
that's a good guess is that yes yeah
yeah 198 thousand one hundred and twenty
five dollars okay that's how much we
made well thank you for coming on again
we had you back on i think it was a
little bit over a year ago you showed up
i was so nervous to meet you man yeah
but it's not that scary where did you
meet me it was you were so nice yeah
like
you afterwards i was talking to jack and
mason like wow he's like he's normal
most accommodating person ever yeah but
like i was shocked that after we
finished he just hung out and talked
yeah he weren't enough to do
yeah i'm not a busy guy now i'm a busy
guy though yeah
but i really appreciate it because like
i feel like i grew up watching your
content like from everything from like
the save the squirrel initiative to the
unboxings of stuff to you like smearing
lipstick on your face and just like
ripping packages open all the content
cops i mean you really like i feel like
you've made like this big mark on
youtube that like changed the way people
approached content for a few years yeah
thank you graeme yeah i i would like to
think that but i don't know like the
lipstick thing i don't know
maybe
that changed everything it was powerful
yeah
yeah
yeah i remember when you were doing the
unboxings i first of all thought it was
crazy that that people would send you
packages like just send you stuff and
you would just unbox it for a video and
make it funny yeah it was cool there's a
lot of really weird stuff that never
really show ended up getting shown on
camera just because it was like
just nasty a lot of nasty stuff
that didn't really like play well to the
camera it's just like you know i don't
know a bag of sand a bag of poop uh you
guys sent a bag of poop yeah lots of
bags of poop like lots of them like
multiple over uh who knows you know i'm
not digging through the bag
open it up if it's you inspect it no
okay
you know yeah got it well how did you
get started on youtube for anyone who's
not familiar with your content or just
like just curious oh yeah i did a lot of
uh gaming back in the day i wanted to be
a
youtube gamer like pewdiepie so i would
commentate on games and then eventually
i didn't get any traction so i switched
to other things like the bad unboxing
and uh and then i think i got bored of
that so i i did another thing content
comps and now i guess i got bored of
that and i did some
documentaries and i'm not bored of the
documentaries but now we're pivoting
into uh boxing
that's your new big shtick huh why why
boxing you know
gotta take out jake paul
is that really your end end game gotta
kill him gotta kill him yeah oh my god
gotta kill him in the ring yeah okay
yeah someone's gotta do it right yeah
someone's gotta do it i've been
disappointed so far because no one's
done it yet yeah yeah we had ben askren
tyrone woodley we were counting on these
guys and they didn't show up so have you
always been into boxing no i feel like
it's so random yeah yeah it seems like
it's completely out of the blue like
you're very conventional traditional
just youtuber and then just boxing yeah
i mean
i think uh anissa has influenced me a
lot just in like
has given me like a lot more confidence
because i
you know i i was i think it's very easy
to have made the content comps that i've
made it's like it's not really that much
work to do research on a person
and compile clips and everything and
like sort of build an argument uh it's a
whole new challenge to like
you know dedicate time and energy to you
know working out six days a week two
times a day
and uh and then eventually put it all on
the line in a boxing event like that's
yeah but much more but arguably there's
other difficult things that you could
choose to do
yeah why did
when you could just keep making more
documentaries that people love
content for the documentary right yeah
so we're going to put out a documentary
once it's all over and that's actually
been the amazing thing is i didn't
realize how hard this was going to be i
actually thought it was going to be
super easy because i was like i'm gonna
face rice gum it's gonna be a piece of
cake first round knockout
uh awesome i don't even have to make a
documentary but it got to the point
where i was like this is so hard i have
to document this i have to
uh sort of tell people my story
uh brett's story a b all these guys who
are involved your story potentially
well it's in i mean i'm not going back
but yeah yeah
i i had something i was about to say and
then you threw me into there and i was
like all right i'm sorry sometimes i ca
what happened what happened with rice
gum why do why couldn't rice come fight
is it is it an issue with money it's
like austin mcbroom got in his head he
you know us mcbroom was lying to
everyone left and right that you can
make three million dollars off of a
fight and that's the money that he
promised a lot of people so he told
ricegum that you can make a lot of money
doing this
and that's exactly why he dm'd anessa in
the first place asking the box
um
but no one's getting paid three million
dollars even one million dollars like
guaranteed to uh to box it's just not
happening unless you're jake paul
got it talk through these specifics
about the fight i know it's for charity
but can you share some numbers behind it
i'm just curious how much how much money
goes into planning something like this
and what do you expect to to make from
this because i know you know charity but
charity aside like you obviously you
have a lot of overhead with this
yeah that's funny that's like the same
question we got on this podcast we just
came back from they they said it in like
a
uh much
i guess less eloquent way they were like
uh so
i know it's for charity but like
there's gotta be some kickback for you
right and i'm like oh no no it's
honestly all is for charity um but yeah
i mean i guess the overhead or like the
cost of putting the event on uh in total
it'll be probably
gosh it'll be close to a million dollars
yeah yeah um after we pay everyone um
yeah and
uh yeah i don't know it's uh
it's it's scary because it's like i
don't know there's a lot of there's a
lot of things to to manage we have a
real good touring is the company we're
working with to
try to get it going they do touring with
uh youtubers
um
and uh they've been super helpful
uh but yeah it we didn't know we were
gonna end up where we're at we were just
scrambling the whole way just sort of
but now what happens if you don't make a
million dollars where does that money
come is this coming out of your pocket
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah uh i mean i've
i've pretty much like
i've already put in uh like 150 000 into
the event um you know but
it we are you know
the the money is is is all but
guaranteed at this point because of you
know the sales of the event and the
in-person ticket so we're pretty much
good we're past the break-even point you
are yes
wow
yeah that's good yes
i was worried so we can actually give
some money to charity thankfully
i was worried about that
that would be the worst case scenario is
like you don't break even you lose money
and nothing goes yeah
but everyone's calling it a charity
event i'd be like oh no
and you know someone's gonna get pissed
at you because it's you're gonna take
some to reimburse your own expense you'd
be like but no he took money yeah he
took money from this he stole from the
charities yeah yeah we're i mean we're
prepared for all of that we're trying to
you know
be as careful as possible we don't want
to do you know the social gloves awesome
room thing
uh but we're not guaran guaranteeing
anyone
absurd amounts of money like we could
end up
if the event literally did only earn a
hundred dollars over a break even yeah
that would just go to charity so so you
got into boxing because you wanted a
challenge that's why you figured what
you were doing beforehand was a little
bit on the easier side and you really
wanted to see what you could do yeah a
little bit it was like a calculated
challenge where it was like
it's rice gum piece of cake i could do
that that was just your initial idea was
just that you would fight rice gum did
you even plan on throwing this huge
event or would it just be you versus
ricegum oh it would have just been me
versus ricegum and i was hoping that
there would be like a trailer or a
showtime that would pick it up and work
with us but none of them want to work
with us why because they don't
understand the value they don't
you know they look at the boxing
audience and they're like well none of
these you know boxing fans are
interested or i've ever heard of you
uh they don't you know they don't take
the youtube audience very seriously i
can even send them like a rice gum video
that i made that has 50 million views or
whatever it is
and it
would have like no effect
but see i view this kind of from their
perspective in the sense that like let's
just say you say this boxing event is
going to get 10 million views
guaranteed they could just go to someone
else and say well you just make a video
and within a week it'll get 10 million
views like you go to the stokes twins
and it's like hey just make a video
about anything 10 million views is there
like low end so i think from their
perspective they would view the boxing
as a bit more of a risk when they could
take a sure thing with uh established
channel right
what do you mean
in terms of like in terms of viewerships
in terms of uh sponsoring or in terms of
paying for anything like that they'd
probably rather take the sure thing
showtime just anyone right if if they're
producing an event they would if their
thing is exposure they're probably
easier ways to get the same amount of
exposure oh i mean i wouldn't see it as
exposure i would see it as money right
like i mean it's it's all untested so i
i i get your point in that way yeah yeah
but i don't know you just write it in
the contract you know ricegum idubbbz
make three videos about this or whatever
i don't know right
why i'm still trying to feel white body
there's plenty of other sports it wasn't
just to fight ricegum i feel like
there's got to be something deeper that
was your beef with ricegum real like did
you actually want to get in the ring
with him and you know go hand to hand i
mean no i mean i'm not that i mean i'm
not a huge fan of the guy but it's
pretty surface level it's not like he
yeah
kicked my dog or anything
uh
but yeah i mean it's pretty surface
level beef especially like at this point
um
[Music]
have you guys talked like off camera you
know like shot each other at dm maybe
that didn't we yeah we've got
back and forth but
like i mean he's the same guy you know
in the dms got it okay yeah you know
everywhere else yeah and it's just like
a lot of like
you know excuses yeah and
all the rest just uncooperative
but first i want to thank our sponsor
ftx us ftx is one of the most complete
crypto and finance apps out there and it
allows users to buy and sell nfts with
no fees whatsoever ftx is one of the
largest cryptocurrency exchanges in
terms of daily users and trading volume
and they're valued at over eight billion
dollars and you may have heard of ftx
through some of their partnerships with
people like tom brady steph curry
coachella or the miami heat stadium most
exchanges charge two to three dollar
minimum fees on every transaction but
with ftx you can trade as much as you
want all for free and their founder sam
bankman freed plans to give away 99 of
what he personally makes to charity they
also make dollar cost averaging super
easy with things like reoccurring buys
where they can pull money directly from
your bank account on a weekly bi-weekly
or monthly basis and invest it for you
automatically and they even offer a
crypto friendly debit card allowing you
to spend your crypto at millions of
merchants worldwide so start trading
crypto and nfts with no fees today by
downloading the ftx app with the link
down below in the description again guys
the link is down below in description to
start trading nfts and crypto with no
fees today thank you so much ftx and
back to the podcast so he backs out but
you still want to fight because have you
been training at this point yeah and to
be honest like i i could have quit at
that point because but i thought i had
done like a lot of training i we had put
in like
two or three months and i thought that
was a lot
but that wasn't that wasn't anything
i hadn't even gotten into sparring at
that point so
it wasn't a lot of training um but i
thought it was a lot at the time so i
was like i gotta see this through
so that's why we just kept going
and then you organize this massive
creator clash you find an opponent and
you find a bunch of other people that
have the other cards
and then that's where we are here yeah
yeah you're fighting dr mike isn't it dr
mike yeah are you worried about that
because i heard he's been doing this for
like what nine years or something like
that right yeah ten years
legendary box so but if but if you're
going up against somebody like that how
do you why would you agree to that
uh
well i we were honestly just looking for
the person with the most relevancy that
wasn't like
who would like accept the fight um and i
guess the other component is like have
they boxed before like have they
um we want to we want all these matches
to be super even so uh and fair so
we knew he had boxing experience so it
wasn't gonna be unfair in that way um
but uh he hasn't done a you know proper
fight
like jake paul or something like i
wouldn't want to fight like
ksi or anisson gibb or any of these
people who have actually gone in the
ring because i feel like that's much
more of an advantage than just saying
like yeah i do boxing fitness for the
past 10 years so he hasn't sparred no
i mean at this point he has but when i
contacted him he he had just been doing
boxing fitness interesting okay and your
game plan with this is throw this event
and are you going to continue boxing
after the event and trying to find more
opponents and just climbing up the
ladder yeah i mean if i successfully am
able to climb the ladder i'll climb it
you know
one rung at a time
yeah
but uh i'm super
interested in the other aspect which is
throwing an event and like continuing to
do these events every year i think that
would be very cool
it's uh the sport has been very
awesome to learn and uh i don't know we
we've fallen in love with it anis has
been doing the boxing with me uh she
hasn't missed a single session we do all
of our sessions together so
we're uh we're
you know
fully
uh involved in the sport now
it's challenging
i i have days where i'm i i have just
second guess myself it's bad like why
did i agree to this yeah yeah totally
yeah
i remember
i'm so surprised and first of all i'm so
surprised graham agreed to it i honestly
am because graham dummies like all right
so ian ian told me that i could fight
michael reeves in this boxing match
should i do it and he was like he was
like on and off for how long was that
like four weeks no it was a long time
that you were that you were giving like
asking for opinions whether or not you
should do it i
am i'm so glad you did it or you
accepted because yeah it's like
it feels bad now but i think once it's
all over with you'll be very glad that
you did yeah it was tough for me because
i look at everything from like you know
financial roi and it's like well how
much how many hours
am i no really like how many hours am i
putting in this what's the risk i'm not
making any money doing this
um i'm subjecting myself to a lot to
push myself through this
is it worth it is this really the best
use of my time right now and but i do
but i just felt that like i would look
back 10 or 20 years from now and be like
i should have taken that risk because
i've never done anything like this
before so that's why when i tell people
they're like really
doing that and it's
you know at least i want to prove to
myself that i could actually do it hell
yeah you know whether i win or lose at
least i i gave it a shot and i tried
yeah no that's the way i see it and
that's so badass i think everyone who
actually you know gets in the ring
deserves all the kudos because it's so
[ __ ] hard like
uh it's scary yeah you know every time
you every time i spar i get [ __ ]
nervous i get super nervous it's it's a
very scary sport and uh
yeah i mean you're putting it on the
line that's good yeah but then but then
i also doubt like am i am i good enough
if if like it is my stance okay am i am
i training enough am i not you know what
what could i improve on am i too scared
like it was really because i've never
gotten a fight in my life and so even
hitting like anything did not come
natural to me same so
yeah but even the the boxing instructor
wants me to like kind of like he'll put
the pad up he's like okay give me a give
me a
hook to this and that's like i i don't
want to
you know because i'm like it's going to
hurt he's like just do it he's like if
you hurt me you hurt me and i'll like
kind of do it soft he's like you got to
do it harder than that
and so i
part of me worries that like i like i
like michael reeves you're not supposed
to
okay i i really don't like michael reed
but like
i don't want to hurt him like i would
feel terrible if i like even just make
him feel bad like wow feel bad i
couldn't like that's that's probably the
next step is just knowing that it's a
sport and that he's he's there to hurt
you so you got to hurt him it would be
really entertaining if you guys were in
the ring together just too scared to
throw punches it would be really
entertaining probably go viral so
we just
we just michael yeah each other we just
like the entire time apologize after
hitting the other person yeah i'm sorry
man you okay
bring it back up
but i mean that's what i also like about
this event is you know most of our guys
i shouldn't even say most i don't think
anyone has any type of feud or you know
dislike for the other person and we're
not trying to force any of that
um
and
it's cool to show people that that's not
what you need because there's a lot of
people who didn't agree to this and they
said like stuff like uh
oh yeah i couldn't fight you know so and
so i have too much respect for them and
it's like you're just a [ __ ]
you're just not saying yes because
you're scared
uh and there's like a lot of weird kind
of macho excuses along the way
where you could just tell they didn't
want to do it but they didn't they
didn't they weren't honest about it they
were like you know
so i have a question when you were
coming up with the idea of
stephen versus reeve um
stevens
yeah stephen
yes
he said that anyway keemstar
when you're coming up with the idea of
stephen versus reeve uh
what made you think in your head i
should bring michael and ask graham if
he wants to fight him did you think he
would say no like what were your initial
thoughts in well i remember i saw you
guys talking about on the podcast and i
was filming a video with uh will william
osman and uh
michael reeves was there just to kind of
do a cameo and uh
i was like okay i'll ask him like
because i was i was kind of nervous to
ask because i was like i know like oh
like you michael pretty much
like over half the card i was like
they're going to be way too busy to say
yes no way they're going to say yes just
out of busyness
and michael just immediately was like
yep i'll do that
it's like what okay like i gotta find an
opponent for him it was gonna be uh
captain sparkles but then captain
sparkles was like now i'll kill whoever
i'm in the ring with yes
so then it was like graham and
what the hell like this isn't even i
actually like your
your response was the biggest surprise
ever anyone for sure really yeah of
course you're the financial guy
everyone's shy i would tell them that
yeah
yeah and you're bringing in like a whole
different crowd to boxing that like i
mean they're not involved in the sport
at all right yeah yeah it's like i would
say
your name and harley's name are the two
that people react to the most when i
bring up the uh events to like strangers
yeah yeah it's awesome
man you're getting stressed out yeah
because today was an off day for me i
had training earlier today and it was a
really bad day and i had a bit of a
headache going into it i didn't have the
energy i sometimes when like you're in
the zone i'm working and then i have to
stop it to go
it's a bad day so but but it's those
days where i just i doubt it it's normal
all of it's normal i've had some like
particularly on this trip it's been
pretty bad like it is so constant
but part of the reason i said yes uh was
because a while ago i forget it was
either jack or yeah somebody asked me
like would you ever do a boxing match or
like something like that and i jokingly
said only if it's michael reeves because
i remember when we did a video together
we got like head to head we were the
exact same height and i felt like at
least i feel like i would have a chance
it's meant to happen yeah so when you
said michael i'm like well that you know
i'm not gonna back down from that i put
it out in the universe and it happened
now if you put me against captain
sparkles immediate note because i've
seen him at the gym he is jacked not
only that but he has a few inches on me
too like i think he's like five eight or
something like that um but and he's just
massive like yeah no i would be dead but
at least with michael i feel like okay
at least it could be a somewhat even
match i think we started training at the
exact same time
i think he took more time off in the
beginning but now i think he's doing
more training than i am so i've had like
a little bit longer but he's doing more
frequent
so yeah it freaked me out to see uh
somebody posted on reddit uh a little
clip of michael fighting yeah you know i
can't really differentiate between like
good or bad i don't know
it looked good to me and so i saw this
i'm like oh man like can i am i at that
caliber i don't know and it psyched me
out a little bit to see that that's
normal yeah yeah just use that i mean
just know that like
we don't know if you're like you could
be awesome just as just as easily as you
could be terrible
you know once you're put in that
situation you know you gotta you gotta
nut up and then you might yeah maybe you
have a bad first round and you're like
oh i can't embarrass myself like this
and you go crazy
it could happen yeah yeah maybe
yeah i want to see that yeah don't count
yourself out i don't yeah i don't know i
just and the other thing is i don't want
to get hurt and i know i know i brought
this up to you before i just like
because for me it's like my my head my
brain is like the most important thing
and if that gets hindered in any way
it's not worth it
so i know you're going into that with a
slight risk
yeah um
yeah and well another thing i think you
should think about as far as like roi
goes
is like um
the return on like
uh growth as a person like uh
mental emotional like this is
challenging you in ways that your brain
is probably not used to right right
like that's that's pretty big i think
that'll help you like maybe maybe do
some good investments in the future
don't you think no i don't i don't
i don't think so i think the only thing
it will prove is that you know at least
i could put myself out of my comfort
zone and knock on would be okay you'll
be the most badass financial guy out
there true yeah i had that uh uh what's
his name kevin meet kevin yeah he
reached out to me in the email wanting
to box too really why didn't you put him
in that you should uh well it was kind
of late
you should have put him in yeah but i
mean
he needs i told kevin to do it you did i
was with kevin when he emailed you yeah
yeah
yeah afterwards he's wanted to fight
grant cardone yeah oh that's awesome
yeah and he posted a tweet
it was i thought it was kind of funny
but grant cardone blocked him on twitter
so he said let's see if you could punch
as good as you block oh that is good i
like that yeah i don't think he's going
to say it yes no unfortunately but you
should have gotten if if you got kevin
in there i thought that would have been
that would have been that would have
been creator clash two is totally yes
kevin would do it 100 hell yeah kevin
versus andre jake yeah that would be a
great fight i think he actually texted
andre before he asked grant and andre
said no
yeah i think you get those two to fight
that would be great yeah because i feel
like they're about the same height
and they could they both have their
strengths i think kevin has more reach
maybe andre is a little bit more like
quicker you know oh yeah yeah so that
would be a good a good fight oh yeah
just do a financial fight i love that
financial fire it's fine you call it
financial [ __ ] well have that like a
sponsored segment in between all the
other fights yeah yeah
so yeah so anyway it's uh it's been up
and down for me i'm looking forward to
i'm i the closer it gets the more
nervous i'm getting
yeah
that's i mean
everything that you're feeling is super
normal just know that you know we're
we're all doing it together
you know you're if if
it's gonna be it's gonna be sick
you know you're gonna
you hey
here's a question yeah uh
part of the reason why i thought
that you accepted this is because you
were like
all right i gotta make this like the
most financially viable thing for myself
as possible kind of like your like logic
with uh the buying the pokemon card
packs from logan oh yeah you like broke
that down like
17 videos out of it and this and that
yeah um you have any plan for this like
i can make
five videos
i can
get sponsored none of it's none of it's
financial i i don't want to say i'm
having a difficult time getting sponsors
but because it's like
they don't know the numbers and
the sponsor is going to be like okay
well a logo on the the jacket or the
pants or whatever what price do you put
on that and then it's also like well if
i'm doing this for charity
do i just donate the money instead like
that's not the point i'm not doing this
for the money because then i may as well
just do a sponsored video instead right
right so
awesome this is good for you then uh
it's one of the few things that i've
done that's not driven by money i love
that one of the few things the aquarium
was something that's not driven by money
this is nice
but that aquarium
like guests who walk into your home
they're really wowed by that yeah and
impressed they're like this guy must be
kind of like an important guy pretty
wealthy because of the aquarium yeah
maybe i should uh you know keep moaning
on this guy yeah maybe i should send him
some money
maybe we should subscribe i haven't done
that already
gosh no this it's not financial driven
at all i love it but yeah but i don't i
don't even have a sponsor uh lined up
for this i don't even know if i'm gonna
do a sponsor hey i don't i don't even
know i can't make a video about this i
mean it's like i could do one afterwards
whether i win or lose i will do a video
um
expressing my thoughts mm-hmm so like
but i'm not i don't be like well i could
do a video from it and yeah and probably
that there's no way that video could be
sponsored because then it takes away
from the message of the video it's like
a heartfelt message and then like oh by
the way
i want to thank i don't know if it's you
know clorox for sponsoring this video
the best thing that could happen for you
is that you get a massive black eye and
you just make a video and put yourself
in the thumbnail yeah that's a that's a
really good thing yeah i'd be fine with
the tie honestly and then it's like you
know you'll be fine with a tie
i'm sorry you're going to win
don't say it don't say that on wreck
you're supposed to
at least feign confidence yeah but but
but then if i if i downplay it and i'm
better no that's that's fair i'd be fine
if if yeah if everyone got a tie so
wrong
i'd be fine it was really entertaining
do i get a participation trophy or
something for just like just coming in
there i i might be able to give you some
sort of ribbon or something
just like a like a pin or something
right like we'll get some like real
second place
i don't know the second place
yeah it'll be
man it will
it will probably be you know one of the
most memorable things you do in your
life which is i think worth it you know
i'm proud of you yeah you're very proud
yeah but i don't know if jack's gonna
make it jack i'll put you on the spot
here
yeah
i know i want i mean i want to go so
badly but i planned a trip to new york
with uh my best friend
like four months ago before the date
even got released and it just so happens
and we went for a concert it's the exact
same day as the concert i really want to
go it's going to be a beautiful ceremony
if jack doesn't go to this i mean it's
this is only this might only happen once
it's certainly grey will not blocks
again this is graham's only time boxing
i want to go so badly i really want to
go and i told graham like i've told him
for the past like two three months i'm
like dude i want to be in your corner i
want to be like cheering you on the
entire time and grammar
every single time i say that
yeah because you want to downplay it you
don't want to make it like a big deal
graham you're going to go in there
you're going to win by knockout first
round are you not nervous for your fight
yeah i'm nervous what are you most
nervous about with this whole event is
like the success of the event the
turnout is it about winning your fight
about everyone having a good time
uh yeah i want the fans to have a really
good time i want the event to be a
success the fight itself is interesting
because it's gonna be so unlike anything
like you can try i think you wanna
simulate
as close as you can what it's gonna feel
like to be in the ring
so like getting into a boxing ring
that's like probably first step uh you
know uh
getting used to people screaming it at
you that's like another thing you should
probably you know
be prepared for focusing all that sort
of stuff and it's
everyone who's talked me about it has
basically said like yeah there's no way
that you can
actually be
like completely ready for it
you can just get as close as you can you
know but first i want to thank our
sponsor ladder hey alex i think i'm
getting ready to start a family don't
you need a girlfriend for that don't
push it alex and when i do i want to be
sure that i can help protect them
financially if anything bad were to ever
happen and i think i now understand why
people get life insurance and with term
coverage being so affordable it really
doesn't make sense not to a healthy 35
year old man can get his family a
million dollars in coverage for only 35
dollars a month you can get ladders easy
to apply for and affordable life
insurance coverage from the comfort of
your own home in just a few minutes just
sign up from your phone or laptop and
ladders smart algorithms will let you
know instantly if you're approved there
are no hidden fees and you can cancel it
anytime you want and if you change your
mind within the first 30 days you can
get a full refund life insurance only
gets more expensive as you age so now's
a better time than ever to cross that
off your list so go to ladderlife.com
iced coffee to get your free quote today
that's
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
iced coffee to get your free quote thank
you so much ladder and back to the
podcast now you're wearing this uh
sweater mm-hmm i want to see the
physique
yeah i want to see what's wrong with
wants you to take off your clothes all
right
all right you might have to censor this
you don't have to sound graham you
should too man what take it out i'm not
gonna no no i just just the shirt oh
just like just the jacket
that's all
look at this thickness
that's that shield your eyes there's too
much thickness here oh yeah that's thick
oh i blend into the background a little
too much
that's a good look that's a really good
look you definitely look a lot bulkier
so what's that what's the the plan with
this is it just you're eating a lot of
food you're trying to bulk up now and
then you're gonna then you're gonna cut
afterwards or yeah i'm probably going to
cut after the [ __ ]
um wait you're going to cut absolutely
just trying to put on weight and you're
not trying to do anything no i have to
eat every day like a lot of food because
i'm one 85-ish right now and we're
meant to weigh in at 190 and he's like
200 so he needs to come down to 190.
isn't that dangerous for you
i think it's more dangerous for him yeah
it's the opposite is that how weight
classes go so if you're going up you're
you're more like advantaged than
somebody uh just depending on the
situation like obviously like
for me it's going to be more um
maybe more fat than muscle i don't know
you look huge you look massive i just
i'm raising my
there we go all right there we go that's
what we're talking about all right got
some large boys in the iced coffee room
there we go
oh nice
it's interesting to me because
how big yeah show us your butt man
well this is kind of a
everything's real
oh you've got your dark i can take my
pants huh yeah go for it man
last time we were together you took off
your pants too
i know oh yeah yeah but you made them do
that it did i didn't make them
wow
that's crazy yeah that's
yeah i didn't know you had a dumpy back
there man yeah that's huge yeah yeah
yeah it's all dark congratulations yeah
yeah thank you yeah i do definitely see
like a big physique change
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean we've been
weightlifting alongside boxing
uh you know gotta get bigger to face off
against mike um
i just hope that i'm gonna be big enough
yeah for me i i've been losing a little
weight which is good yeah yeah so i've
i'm down four pounds the last two months
so i don't i don't need to lose a lot
but like just around my stomach i've
just not been happy with that so that
area yeah like leading up to this or is
it just yeah the last like ever since
kovid uh i got that little bit of a gut
yeah yeah okay so it's getting shaved
off now slowly hell yeah no six-pack yet
no okay no like maybe two in the right
light yeah in the right lighting
uh
in the morning before i eat anything
maybe that's cool yeah that's probably
closer you're probably closer to it than
i am really yeah okay yeah check this
out
i can see something i see the lines
yeah i think right
yeah
yeah water retention anissa says
would you uh box jack yeah a box yeah
yeah i would do it would get in the ring
would you box kevin
kevin asked me really if i would
yeah honestly i told him that you know i
would just do it if in his backyard if
he really wanted to
i've never boxed anyone before uh it
sounds fun i worry that with kevin such
like in it i don't want to say like he
has that like addictive personality but
he's so just like laser focused on
something that i worry that he would
like put everything aside and just train
train training like he would never train
how has training been with like all that
you have to do because like i've stopped
doing pretty much everything to train
and i imagine that's got to be tough for
you given that you know you got a lot of
a lot of things to do yeah so i've been
doing three times a week since i don't
know when did we start january february
january i think so three times a week
um i've
just recently well like as of two weeks
ago i stepped it up to now four times a
week awesome so tuesday thursday
saturday sunday
um
it's difficult yeah yeah
those back-to-back days were tough and
this last week because i missed a sunday
for easter i had to do fridays i know
thursday friday saturday and that
saturday was
horrible have you have you started
sparring uh the trainer i've not sparred
a person i don't know but i've been
sparring the trainer and he just wears
the big thick
gloves when he's doing this
and uh
yeah he he i think he's he's kind of
training me to not put my hands down and
so anytime i do the wrong move he just
and he's so quick with the bumps so he's
he's getting all the bops in but he says
that uh like with his experience he's
gonna be
better than any opponent that i would
ever do and he could control like what
he hits
so yeah so sometimes i'll throw a hook
and he'll just know i've opened myself
up yeah it's so fast yeah so and then
he's been training me to you know
when anytime i do this you gotta drop
and roll and do this thing over here and
uh it's a lot of memorization yeah of
just like different things i'm gonna do
this you're gonna do that and if you see
this i want you to do that and it's just
like yeah it's a lot more intricate than
i thought yeah it's yeah you kind of
have to let it go a little bit like you
maybe overthink things because i do that
when i'm especially when i got started
yeah and you just need to like feel it
and kind of zone out a little bit to
make it happen sometimes right rather
than thinking like all right now i'm
about to do a roll you know it's like
yeah right just roll yeah and there's
been a few times i've been i've been hit
in the head and it's just like i've
never felt that like sensation before
and there's one that just like he hit me
like here and it just knocked i've never
like had my neck just go back instantly
and there was that quick like second was
like what was going on because i just
caught me off guard yeah and then a few
other times like hit in the stomach and
it just like gets the wind out of you
and in that like second
you can't you feel like a little
disoriented but you can't
just like put your hand on what was that
because yeah then you're done totally
yeah yeah yeah absolutely i mean you're
gonna you know it getting punched will
be second nature to you by the time
you're done with your training you'll be
like yeah yeah i can take a punch but
i've i've noticed usually that uh you
know if i if i carve out the time i'll
have the time for it yeah you know you
just you make that a priority and and
i've i've been worried obviously like
before like how am i gonna have the
extra like i can't even do an extra hour
for this how am i gonna do an hour for
this
but the funny thing is it's like when
you carve out that hour you're more
productive in the other hours
yeah so i totally i've not noticed any
decrease in anything really cool yeah
that makes sense i think the um i looked
at the lineup and i gotta say i think
the one i'm most scared about is i'm
scared for a bee
i mean i looked at who's his opponent
i have no clue who he is but i looked at
his picture right here
jesus christ i am
i'm terrified for you right now like you
look at look at look at this
oh my gosh
show a b uh pull up a picture of a b
a b i like i i like you man but that's
hilarious alex would you box
yeah man yeah why not yeah who would you
box well it's hard to find an opponent
that's my size so
you know it because people my size are
either freaking
arnold schwarzenegger the rock
right so i i need somebody that's like
physically in the same kind of realm as
me because i want it to be a challenge i
don't want it to feel like i'm gonna get
completely destroyed
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you make that happen wow who knows do
you know him uh i don't but who i think
was like keemstar said oh i got a
contact with nick akavo i'm like all
right
maybe
uh but yeah yeah i've tried reaching out
to him i think twice
never got back you'd have to train yeah
no no not not for boxing just to get him
on the podcast oh yeah i mean that would
be great such an intro because i think
he's playing up a big character and he's
that's what i think he'd be perfect for
this podcast because he makes a bank and
he really knows how to like organize his
channels and like like he is a
a money fiend like i would argue he
makes more money than you with all the
things that he's doing
i would disagree with that but
i don't know but honestly i would love
for him he's got like he's got only fans
yeah he's got like 10 channels he might
be right actually he's got a ton of
weird [ __ ] going on oh he's got cameo he
grinds on cameo
i yeah so i would love to get him on to
talk about the finance ass but i don't
think he ever would because then that
rev then you pull back the curtain
and then not only do you do not see him
the same way as like is he acting is it
not is this him is it not
but then if i'm sure people know how
much he's making
would they support him as much or they'd
be like dude come on like this is too
much it's hard to say i don't think i
don't think it'll would ruin it that
much because he's sort of like i don't
know
i i think his routine only really like i
think it only works on people who like
want to believe it in the first place
like
you know what i mean like uh it's no
because like kids and people who just
find him naturally funny no but even for
me do you think that's it i have a hard
time understanding who his fans are
really yeah i feel like most people just
tune in just for like absurdism it's
just like oh my god yeah oh he's got a
lot of funny routines like
yeah if you watch enough of his stuff
you'd be like you start you watch a lot
of it oh yeah really yeah yeah he's got
man i love this routine where he calls
uh he was like buying the travis scott
meal at mcdonald's a lot yeah
and he kept calling it uh give me the
travis skittles give me the traffic
skittles
this is really dumb but uh you know he's
like pretending to not know what travis
scott's name is
and uh it's just super funny i think he
called him a bunch of
there was he'd do a routine where he
he'd get back home with this mound of
travis scott meals
and he'd like talk to siri and be like
siri who is travis skittles
and it would like pull up like all sorts
of dumb results and he's like and he's
like travis scott scott's travis scott's
or something like that and it would like
bring up like a football player or
something and he just would do that for
i don't know 20 minutes
before he even eats gosh
see i think if uh if people saw that if
it is a character and he's like he's got
a smart business behind he's like yeah i
have a team and this is this and we pull
on this this amount of money and yeah i
have to do this right now but it's doing
so well and
i think people i think he'd a lot of
people gain respect for that but i think
then people would not tune in for the
shock value because they know it's it's
like a business calculated move
and it's working in this favor and if
you watch you're playing into that yeah
uh you might be right i've had this uh
discussion with uh how to basic actually
even the idea of like just revealing his
identity
and uh what's that he should do it yeah
i'm being serious is he on the fence
ever or is it just like a clear no it's
a clear now yeah why oh he just thinks
it would ruin the uh the entertaining
value of the channel like as soon as
people know who he is it's no longer
interesting what that means i agree
yeah i do but that means he has to
continue with how to basic yeah and i've
seen the the recent videos compared like
what he was doing a few years ago
every video was like blowing up but now
i feel like people have seen the same
sort of format over and over and over
again they know what to expect
um
i think i mean
it's maybe not the same as it once was
yeah i would agree with that but he is
in a weird position well i i actually
didn't
i don't think i realized that people
came across this channel accidentally
too often i actually thought like people
were like a little bit more tuned into
it but like i think most of the videos
and views that have gone mega viral have
been legitimately people being like oh
you know
a jello recipe or whatever
they'll click on it like normies and
they'll be completely you know
flabbergasted by that happened to me
really the first time i watched it yeah
just completely surprised yeah yeah so i
think there's like there's just
constantly new people flowing in and
getting surprised by it so like i don't
think he really needs to change it up
too much okay um it's just a different
uh he's got a good system that's
interesting does he work a job
or is it just no youtube he worked at
domino's for a while
are you serious yeah
like while he was still doing it wait
why was he for me
but he can't even share that meme with
anyone oh you shared it with me
so it was just for his friends yeah well
and then when people would ask and what
he does he'd be like i work at domino's
but now here's but how much trust does
he put in the people that know who he is
like how many people would you say in
the planet know who he is and notice i
mean there's probably a few hundred few
hundred yeah for sure wow but how has it
not been leaked by now
uh i mean it's i think it's been leaked
in like
some ways
like it just depends on like where
you're looking
what you're looking at and there have
been so many leaks it's so probably hard
to tell it's
yeah because i did oh gosh when was this
must been a few years ago oh when he did
that the the face reveal yeah and then
max mofo came on and yeah
and i and that got me intrigued to be
like who is this guy so i started
looking up and i saw all these like
videos like this is him and this and but
there's so many of them that i'm sure
one of them is right but you don't know
which one is right yeah
hey was he there the entire time yes
this is uh that's one of my uh many
spells i this is summon uh muslim man
spell what's up this is brett hello hey
brett what's up like lady and the
trampoline we're eating spaghetti
welcome brett thank you
welcome so how long have you been
training for you're gonna be fighting
coming up soon yeah yeah i i've been
enjoying this conversation i don't get
to talk like hear a lot of the other
fighters like what's going through their
heads right this is nice yeah i started
like end of november beginning of
december basically
around the time a b did too i think i
think okay we started yeah they started
way before you guys so what have you
what's your trainer been teaching you
you have the same trainer as michael
reeves yeah his opponent i have two
coaches but yeah well michael started
really late right
when did you start uh january sometime
okay i think michael started february
but michael's been training
more so like he could catch up to me
even though i started a little earlier
yeah can i tell you that his cardio is
really good how's your cardio
i don't know is it is it actually really
good our coach brought us to this like
famous run that like manny pacquiao does
it's up this really tall peak called
dante's peak okay and it was me odd one
odd ones out and um and michael and he
just didn't stop he just ran all the way
up the hill like it wasn't michael did
he didn't affect you doing this to psych
me out are you being serious i have no i
mean i have no yeah i'm hearing your as
a guest
i'm here to help you yeah no he he
really like it didn't affect him i don't
know why because we were dying for sure
he's probably pretty light so that could
help yeah he's like got like field mouse
energy like he's just like he could run
from a hawk for hours i'm not it's not a
bit like so what that means maybe is
when you go to la
you try to do that run and see where
you're at i'm i'm here
basically the entire time through the
fight okay yeah just i mean what's
what's your cardio like
what do you feel do you feel confident
like if you ran on a treadmill for like
half an hour how do you feel at the end
of that i would be able to do a half
hour okay i guess i would start there
yeah
like running for a half hour yeah grams
cardio i don't i don't like sprint on my
runs i i set it for like you know i
don't know i could do a mile like
10 minutes when i was running and i
haven't really done a lot of running but
uh usually it's a six and a half and
i'll keep that going for but usually
i'll do a few minutes at a time a few
minutes uh
quick walk a few minutes of that quick
walk so you've done running before so
it's like we used to run yeah we did
like uh what a year and a half ago we'd
go for runs like quite frequently
actually it was two miles so a mile to a
park we'd do uh chin-ups on a children's
playground yeah yeah sometimes we
couldn't if they were playing on the
plane it's so awkward
for them to finish sometimes we'd do it
if they were there yeah
and the parents would be there and so
we'd like wait for them to finish and be
like all right now we could go in and
we'd like do our chin ups like that
and
he's so awkward but yeah it was and then
sometimes they wouldn't leave so we're
like well let's we're not going to tell
them to sometimes we'd wait for them to
leave because we'd like do a few other
lap stuff oh yeah we go around the park
sometimes like just pace but we'd be
like you're watching them yeah we'd be
looking and be like oh they left let's
let's run over michael reeves cardio is
very good yeah is what you're saying my
coach is he gonna be mad at me for
telling for telling you that i mean
that's just a fact he is he's just he's
just see i i see i go to the michael
reeves subreddit and they all say like
oh he's jacked he's jacked he's like and
i've seen the one like he has one
screenshot of him doing this but like
jack doesn't do anything but i don't
know how often he goes to the gym people
are saying he goes to the gym like every
day and i was like maybe i don't know
yeah i think you guys are doing the same
amount to be honest i think he's just a
little bit younger yeah you know um
a little bit healthier i don't know spry
yeah it has a little bit more power
has it in his jeans the box is naturally
gifted
what you were saying though it's like i
think it's going through all of our
heads though right those moments where
you're like what am i doing man like i
we've all i think we've all had yeah
like it's not just you
like literally everyone michael is
feeling that right now yeah like that is
happening no one's like i could do this
i'd like to go through what his head
like what he would say about me if he or
if he's like oh grandma he's old
he's not gonna you know his back is
hurting it's not gonna
uh he he would probably say that i think
you'd say something like yeah he's old
but i i don't think he he means it i
think it's a little bit of a front
because i think everyone is like
everyone that i've talked to candidly
has been like yeah it's not it's not
easy and it's i'm yeah i am nervous and
all the rest everyone's full of [ __ ]
that
that actually says that they're you know
they're confident yeah jake paul i like
kind of believe it because he's gotten
to the point where like his confidence
has been boosted yes but you talk to him
on the before the first fight candidly
and he's be like yeah i'm pissing myself
like for sure sure human nature yeah and
those bad training days like
we all have them oh who's fighting first
and who's last um i think we're gonna
have uh nathan barnett dad
uh versus matt watson first why uh just
because it's like uh
i think it's
hmm how do i put it
it's one of the more
interesting fights
um but i don't think they've spent as
much time
as some of our other fighters training
so they're like in this kind of middle
ground area where it's like most
entertaining
like a dynamic because they've done like
diss tracks and stuff on each other so
it's like i think it's a good way to
start the show
uh but we don't want to you know we
don't want to have like the biggest
names first obviously okay and then
obviously the last one is going to be me
and dr mike
where where am i going to be
uh well because you guys are
uh you know some of the bigger names we
got to have you like at least final four
somewhere final four fights so you guys
are going
right before a b and brett how does that
make you feel part of me wanted to go
first
really like as being yeah because then
it's they get it over with
you just kind of the rest of the night
right and because i know i'm not going
to be able to think or concentrate on
anything
um
until until i go so part of me thought
well if i'm first
then at least i enjoy the rest of the
night yeah that is good logic because it
is going to be but then also you don't
sit like there is no standard or
precedent like if everyone's really good
it's then i feel like there's a bar that
needs to be set and by going first
there's no bar it's just no expectation
it's just go and do it that's a great
point
yeah that would be a good good reason
if you're not confident yourself well
i'm just saying you could put us first
uh to get all the people in and then
once they're watching
continue okay
maybe we'll order the uh the fights in
like weight classes
yeah see that's a good i there we go
it's settled we'll do that
i think you're good i think it's gonna
be a good fight i think it's going to be
a good matchup i think so too oh thanks
because i mean at your weight class you
guys move completely differently like
you're definitely you're going you're
faster than all of us we're all in this
like stupid weight category where we're
really slow
um and i think you guys will be super
entertaining your your fight and uh
minx and yodeling haley those would be
two very different fights than what
people are used to
oh i'm curious what are you doing to
make money during all this i'm not
you're not making any money i'm not
making any money during this uh event
planning and just living off the savings
yep living off savings uh there's a
little bit of youtube money trickling in
uh we got only fans on the back burner
that's bringing a little bit in i mean
it's covering rent and
some other expenses so i got a question
for you yeah nfts how many you got zero
oh no why
do you have nfts no i don't have any
inputs
yeah i don't have any nfts no you're not
in the nft space i don't get it yeah i
don't understand it no yeah well it's
yeah it kind of sucks
i agree yeah
i'd rather yeah i'd rather but you are
in a little bit in crypto yeah bitcoin
and ethereum
no nfts you should get one at nft
just uh just to appeal to the young
crowd i'm too old for that
i don't get nfts and i get a lot of the
altcoins i don't understand a lot what
about have you seen like uh like what
gary vee's doing the v friends yeah yeah
i think it's interesting
but his is more about the utility behind
it of like if you get this you could get
access to his like conferences and this
and that's a network i at least
understand it yeah it's better than a
picture of just like some
dog
and then well no no it's in a single
dogecoin i'm just like a cat it doesn't
matter just a picture of an animal on it
it's like it's worth more because it's
only 10 of them and it has this animal
on it yeah
yeah
that's fair i think uh yeah garyvee's
thing is interesting yeah
i went on the website and i was like
going through all the different like uh
the v friends and it's so funny when you
click on like what each one of them does
like a video of gary pops up and he's
like
this is the workout eagle if you got
this this means that i'll skype you and
we'll do a workout together for 10
minutes
uh and there's just like a ton of
different ones but it makes sense to me
there's a price that someone's willing
to pay yeah for a skype call plus a
workout oh totally how much is it and
but to be able to sell that uh to
somebody else who wants it you could
make your money back and someone else
gets it i i think it puts more power in
that in that circumstance to the
consumer like imagine he just says hey
for a thousand dollars skype call and
workout pay that it's done but if you
own the rights to that skype call and
workout you sell it to somebody else
maybe they're gonna pay more maybe they
pay less but you'll recoup some of your
money he gets some of some of it back
someone else gets it for what they're
willing to pay
that's the weird part about it though is
like it doesn't
in its form it's like it's supposed to
be proving like what this uh
like uh
that it that it's something owned but if
it's like a ten minute skype call it's
like once you use it it's essentially
expired a groupon yeah it's like a group
maybe so you almost may as well just
like have a kickstarter project or any
other website that essentially promises
it doesn't even need to be on a
blockchain like yeah i mean
yeah i think nfts are going to be huge
but not in the sense of like a
collectible but i could totally see
gucci on every bag that they do is going
to be attached to an nft just to verify
that it's authentic cars i think would
go the same way
a lot of stuff that you could do you
could verify authenticity and ownership
through an nfc i don't think it's going
to be like the nft is the value i think
it it would be the medium of how you
verify things
so it's like
it's good but i don't think that's the
value valid
well said that's what i think so and
here's the thing too imagine you could
you could have done an nft for this uh
clash event and that's how you get entry
i mean like if you buy this nft just
charge the same price you would for a
ticket
except they get to keep the nft it
doesn't cost them anything extra
and
you know maybe maybe the front row maybe
the front row should have
you know 50 nfts just for the front row
that's how they get in there
and um
maybe those are worth more because it
turns out to be a fantastic event and
just auction them and then just
literally do that yeah coachella did it
but and it works but but you would get
for those front row 50 seats people are
willing to pay whatever the market is
the problem is it feels like they are
it's
it's
i think a lot of people think it's like
a limited thing but because
everything can technically be made into
an nft i watched like this seminar was
like quentin tarantino and like uh like
his team of nft gurus were like talking
about like you can make every frame
of uh
pulp fiction or that one scene uh an nft
and sell it and that was like most
brilliant thing but it's like yeah like
is it is it the frame before like what
if you make the frame right after it
like an nfc as well it's like it's like
it's infinite so it's value's going to
be attached to whatever and the mean
like with the
gun and samuel jackson like that's a
meme that was created by someone else
it's also an nft yeah potentially its
value is going to be whatever people
think it's going to be but that's the
market price but but where it gets
sketchy is when people make big promises
or this you can buy this nft and you're
going to flip it
that's the danger but if someone's doing
an nft and it's and it's attached to it
like if you do it in
exchange of a ticket you get an nft
that's how you get in it doesn't cost
anything extra you're getting something
for free that they can hold on to yeah
yeah if they care about it maybe maybe
not but yeah yeah i wonder
make a video about nfts
oh yeah i've been working on an nft
video have you really oh yeah hate the
darn things
i'm with you i'm with
oh i don't know probably half the boxing
gosh i'm looking forward to seeing it
yeah it's not particularly controversial
it's just same
in here all right yeah i'm looking
forward to it well thank you guys so
much for coming on i really appreciate
it looking forward to it i guess i'll
see you the next time maybe in florida
i'll see you
boxing day yeah
prepare
for war
all right
okay thanks so much reeves let's end it
on this i'm gonna give him a free stock
down below in the description when he
signs up for public using the code
graham because that stocks worth all the
way to a thousand dollars you can't do
that to his face what are you gonna do
to his face
get a bankroll call yeah i can ban no
i'm gonna show him which stock i got
i'm going to be like michael here's what
i got what are you going to do to dr
mike's face kiss it
well there we have it
all right thank you guys thank you
until next time
bye